people of the internet retro racking
tour here guys just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell welcome
back to the wand waggling Adventure that
is Harry Potter and the Order of the
Phoenix one of the comments I saw
recently cracked me up said something
about spaghetti arm Harry it it it's so
true man it's so true but we are back
here in the room of requirement it seems
that the game places you back here every
time regardless of where you save unless
I'm doing something incorrect which is
entirely possible but I think that's
just how the game works so we are I
think we were a little bit over the
halfway point and how many students that
we need to recruit and you see all our
tasks over here on the right in addition
to the students though we also have some
for teachers which I'm honestly not sure
what that does exactly they call them
mini like a mini Quest right there for
Flitwick a mini quest for Snape so I
think we start off this video by
tackling some of those and we'll start
with our boy Flitwick here because I've
I remember passing him several times
he's just standing out out in front of
his uh classroom looking all lonely we
can't have that so we're going to head
on over to flip Wick and who knows maybe
we'll find some Secrets along the
way but I can see the excitement of me
bringing back this series I know you
guys had been waiting for it for a
while and it's finally here discover
scoundrel and by the way if you guys are
enjoying these don't forget to hit that
like button down below that's going to
help even more people even more Harry
Potter fans out there find these
videos all right so dude I just
the castle it really is pretty
impressive considering for when the game
released I mean I know it kind of gets
boring going up and down these stairs
over and over and over there we go all
for another adventure are we we are
indeed but it's it's kind of the same
Adventure that we've taken a couple of
times success a healthy this one might
give us a little bit something different
to do we'll
see I don't remember the teacher
challenges at all if you guys remember
from the last episode see look at our
look at Flitwick man he looks so lonely
right there he's like please come into
my
class I hope the three of you have
completed your research into counter
charms for your homework remember your
owl exams May influence your futures for
many years to come yes of course
Professor there's just one more counter
charm I need to check before I my essay
in uh yeah can't do it right now I know
the perfect book achievements in
Charming but it's been checked out from
the library we'll need to find Whoever
has it I was going to say I I bet I bet
we have to go find it all right we need
to find Whoever has it like how where
where should we begin there just one
more counter charm I need to check
before iand my essay in I wonder who's
got the library book we
need oh my goodness dude that is too
funny he says I wonder who's got the
library book she's like I don't know I I
don't know I mean okay so first thought
maybe we go check the library maybe
they're still actually in the library so
let's go ahead through our list here
Mark that
one and wait for our Footprints to
appear there they are yeah I was
thinking we'd go this
way oh it's just
right yeah I I knew I knew where it was
I knew it was there guys I just want to
make sure that yeah you all saw the the
footprints and yeah just want to make
sure but we're here now that's that's
all that matters the only question is is
the book actually here the person who
has the book good day maybe if we just
wander around long enough we've seen
this happen a few times before Hermione
and oron will eventually be like hey I
think we should go here to find this
okay what are you doing
here
a it looks like we should be able to
move that doesn't it
dep can we go in that's terrific we've
discovered a Fred and George hidden I
didn't see what the last part
said oh and then it just goes back oh
but we can't actually go in here can we
I'm sorry guys I'm trying to move the
camera but as you know this game does
not give you that sort of camera control
wait I just used the
d-pad oh d-pad is kind of
like used as a little bit of a lock on
all right so Hermione now do you want
there's just one more count I need to
check beforeand my essay end I wonder
who's got the library book we
need how are you fairing all
right yeah yeah that's where we're at
that's where we're at I mean maybe we're
just going to have to do what we did in
the last episode where we decide you
know what the game will eventually lead
us to where it wants to go however we
might as well go ahead and tackle some
of these other objectives since we can
trigger multiple ones so you know what
let's go talk with our boy Colin creevy
here who knows maybe Colin has the book
you
guys maybe maybe Colin is just going to
solve all the problems
here judging by the little description
it seems like we need to help him find
his camera sucess you may pass Mr
Potter I love the music triggers when
you walk in
[Music]
here
okay back to the entrance hall let's see
is it going out here this game gets so
dark in certain
areas it's it's quite hard to see at
times all right why are they moving so
slow come on they want me go this
way dude maybe the person who has the
Charms book what if they were actually
in the charms classroom and I just need
to walk
[Music]
in
hey I think we can light
these come on Harry Mr spaghetti hands
spaghetti arms
himself right
[Music]
here I got to say the the
spellcasting it's strange at first but
it's in a way it's kind of growing on me
it's kind of growing on me I do like
that it's not just Spam a specific
button it just feels very sluggish which
is kind of the overall feel of this game
what's Colin doing I didn't even see
him hi Colin what are you doing I tried
to take a photograph of some siin bully
you first here you know so we'd have
evidence but they threw my camera on the
roof don't worry Harry will get it back
for you you will thanks Harry that's
brilliant up there okay get it whatever
you do I bet it'll be
cool
you now have two tasks to complete I
wonder if we can burn that Branch right
there oh my gosh dude I want you guys to
think about this for a second I mean
clearly you can see what they want us to
do right you guys can see it we are in a
world of
magic no not that we are in a magic
school and if you remember from our boy
Ron you're the youngest sea in a
century and this man can't get him a
broom to fly up
there are you are you kidding me right
now we're going to have to
climb the whole way up
there dude okay first let's see if we
can burn this little Branch right here
who keeps planting these things we yeah
oh we we got to keep going got to keep
wag wagle that wand Harry waggle waggle
waggle all right I think it's done okay
can we hop up here and then just nope no
no can you guys like wingardium this for
me that'd be wonderful okay this one's a
little bit lower maybe we can bring the
bench over
here Wingardium
Leviosa I'm also surprised at how I'm
remembering a lot of these even the ones
you don't use a lot like wingardium
right there
Are You Are you seriously telling me you
can't okay all right we'll try something
different
EXC excuse
me that had to be a Slytherin Umbridge
is the best you discovered a hidden
Hogwart symbol and that is insanely
bright right there it is not just your
all screen I've read all about him I
think people have lied
about starting to make me wonder if
there's like a setting on my PS3 that I
need to change or something it's been so
long since I played this this
[Music]
thing hey another hidden symbol
discovered very
nice
all right can we reparo
this
nice oh and maybe we can climb this
remember we can we've been able to climb
that
before yeah I think maybe that's where
we start to get the camera but I'm just
going to go ahead and finish finish all
this out while we're up
here now see that one's completely clear
you can see that one very clearly
all
right dude there was a lot
to repair and use incendio on up here
there we go that's all four of the
symbols I wonder if this is tied
to getting the camera or if it's just
it's just a little
unlock incendio
[Music]
why is it showing me
that
that it's like they wanted me to go over
there AO
maybe uh Wingard we need to move it
because we can lock on to
him
we can't climb up there either
okay let's head back
down oh wait I do want to see if we can
climb
this let's
go the question is will this take
us let's just go all the way
up all right that's it okay
oh my goodness
Harry how do we get over there can I not
grab that
ledge why can he not grab that
ledge so wait what's the point of this
thing
[Music]
then this is so
bizarre
his hands would be absolutely bloody
wait oh you're near something you can
climb he's just doing that with his bare
hands okay this thing did we do anything
with
this I think we repaired that didn't
we all right well let's see if there's
anything we need to do with those house
crests down
here wardian
Leviosa
oh I think there
is whack a few oh my goodness whack a
few students in the head with the stone
bench right
here
bye okay I wonder if we're just supposed
to position it right on top of
this drop
it is that
it
this is so strange are we are we even
supposed to do anything with these
or man you guys who have this game fresh
in your memory are just screaming at the
screen right now try see you later Harry
no no no call Mate no sorry I came back
I still haven't got my camera down will
you help me Harry
I'm trying to help you dude I can't
figure out how to get up there I
anywhere I try to climb I mean I feel
like this is the logical
place this maybe we need to move the
like let's move the bench over here a
little bit now the other thing we could
try when I can't imagine it's that
complicated though I was thinking like
stack the
benches okay you guys are going to have
to move I'm trying to position it right
here in front all right let's let go
Harry what the heck
dude oh my
goodness it's like where it was on his
head it just got stuck in that
position okay drop it right
here I thought I was actually going to
make stairs for a
second okay climb up on this Harry oh we
can't even climb that now you can't
even you can't even get up there are you
serious right now are you s why can't he
not get up there all right so I mean my
first thought is it they wanted us to
come and just like stand on these here
cuz we've got Slither in there but maybe
we're actually supposed to put the bench
on it that matches like we did here but
it's just nothing happened like it
didn't even it it gave me no sort of
visual indicator that yes this is what
you're supposed to do get up to that
ledge yeah that what do you think we're
trying to do
Hermione let's drop this
here yeah I see like no visual indicator
whatsoever oh come on Harry your magic
should
reach all right camera didn't move so I
can't see where it
is
wait all right it dropped it right where
we need it
to okay and then the Slytherin one is
right over
here well dude it did kind
of let's
go your spells are now more powerful so
wait that was just a
discovery that doesn't move us closer to
Colin at all there are lots of new
things to see in our secret room
Harry it will never not be creepy Myrtle
when you say
that I just want you to know it will
never not be creepy the only thing that
we've been able to successfully climb so
far was
this maybe there's a button that I'm
forgetting to
press that makes him reach over there
and climb up there mate let me let me
try again here let me try Okay Square
Square's not doing anything X's not
doing anything Circle not doing anything
triangle trigger buttons nothing and I'm
I'm pressing in that
direction now if we could actually move
the camera I could kind of look and see
cuz my thought was you climb that and
then you're just going to go all the way
over and
around
that was my second thought anyway my
first thought was that we would just be
able to hop on this bench right here and
climb up here ledge like why can you not
just jump I'm sorry Harry it's got loads
of good pictures of you in it
too creepy much
Colin if only you all may have a slight
hint on how to do it let's can we move
this again when guarda let's put you
over here just drop you right there can
we even climb these anymore is it going
to let me okay it actually let me climb
this now like just it's right there
Harry just you get my camera down w't
you har Colin stop talking please just
jump just jump
man okay okay okay okay did you guys
catch that whenever I walked over here
the camera definitely shifts up I think
clearly it wants us to go in that
direction and there is there is a pipe
right there can we do a
raparo I'm saying it like him now
raparo okay maybe it's the bench maybe
we bring the bench over
there put it kind of right here in the
corner no that's still Way Too
Tall no that's what you're going to
climb
next it has to be this right here man it
has to be
okay I'm going to try this whenever I
try these things that are kind of this
far out there unless it's a game like
tears of the Kingdom it's usually not
going to work because a lot of these
older games were just way more
simplistic and my brain wants to make it
way harder than it needs to
be but I'm just going to try stacking
these here I'm going to try stacking the
two yep just just like that drop it okay
and then we're going to put one in front
of
it now we actually do
have we actually have four of
these like I'm okay so let's drop it
right there I don't think we're close
enough and you know what just just in
case we need
it just in case let's go ahead and get
it over
here actually let's see if we can climb
can we climb we can climb
too
yes let's
go okay see that was one time when it
actually I I never thought they wanted
us to stack them that was one of the
first things I thought too I should have
just tried
it although I still stand by you know if
if he just would would get a broom oh
wow if he would just get a broom we
could have had this done how long we
been going we could have had this done
about 15 minutes
ago if he would have used a broom one of
the most basic magical objects of The
Wizarding
World but you know what Harry it's fine
we're going to make it work Colin we're
going to make this work for you dude
okay how do I step can I do we're going
to need to repair that but how do I step
oh my goodness please don't fall please
do not
fall there we go slide slide
okay oh
no wait what are we supposed to okay
hold on is this what we're supposed to
do do we kind of Step Off a little bit
here and then do we need to repair
that but then
what oh I don't like the looks of this
you guys I don't think I don't think we
can jump over
there maybe we depulso or AO it
off well done Harry try using wardian
laosa to pass it down to us no depulso
no I'm doing
depulso imagine if it bre har you're the
best dude imagine if it broke that's
probably why Hermione suggested we guard
him levosa so we could give it a nice
soft Landing no Colin we're depulso that
off this ledge after everything you've
made us go through you guys should have
enough sense down there on the ground to
uh give it a little arresto
momentum don't worry I
will oh we can just slide all the way
down though okay that is nice that is
nice you can get down much faster but
then they still they're like nah we're
not going to let you get all the way
down that way there's going one more
spot where you have to crawl over at a
snail's pace please Harry come
on
yes All Right wow Harry thanks you're
great I wish I could cast magic like
that just wait till light till Dennis
Harry Potter help me get my camera back
Dennis will be so jealous Harry do you
think you could tell him Theory of how
you got my camera back maybe Harry Will
Tell Dennis if you bring I don't know if
you want us telling this story again of
course I'm not going to miss any of
those meetings Harry you're going to be
a great teacher I know it come to the
room of requirement on the seventh floor
yeah okay I'll be there is there a care
for bring my camera no probably not we
don't want photos of a secret meeting I
won't bring it then great no problem
thanks again Harry I'll see you later
bye I mean this is the book where Harry
is just angry the whole time at least
they both leave Harry we need as many
people on our side as we can get so
maybe when they made this game they're
like okay we're going to give him a
reason to be this angry that's what we
want to do all right wait why is Colin
still Colin wants to learn petrificus
totalis oh my goodness
Colin all right maybe we can knock out
three with this one Fred George and Lee
Jordan let's go ahead and do that one
next we still need to get the book that
Hermione needs apparently some random
student has it we have no idea who the
game is not giving us any indication of
who may have it all right let's do a
little uh
incendio all I know is we're going to
have some pretty powerful spells cuz we
have been finding the secrets now whoa
cinematic shot let's go the nice pan out
of the
camera
don't want to miss
that o what is
this a hidden
parcel that might have been what we
found in the library when we pushed that
bookcase back or
bookshelf
oh sorry let you get let those catch
up ooh the boat house I don't know if
I've been down here
yet wait do you guys give us
something no okay o i see a yep
incendio oh and there's a portrait down
here too wi Guardian
Leviosa oh that's
awesome see if we can feed all three of
them or just I guess you just feed
one nope here Ron you want
one imagine if he actually ate it all
right and then we should be able to do
the one in the middle if Ron will get
out of the
way there we go oh there's more on the
other side
too I wonder if we're supposed to do it
again okay where do you lead good
sir oh he's just asleep right
now wait what was that you're near
something you can climb I
think examine
bet filch should tie us up in those and
feed us to the merman if he
could oh these you just have to walk up
next to nice all right now let's do a
little incendio right
there okay guys what do you need from us
looking for you two we found somewhere
for the da to
practice I hope you're not breaking
school rules we would dream of it would
we Fred not with so many prefects around
we're merely storing items where they
won't disturb over sensitive individuals
like Umbridge and filch will you give us
a hand we need someone to go up inside
the boat house we'll lift the boxes up
to you then if you can pop them in the
boat it would be much
appreciated okay so now we have to go
back in there and climb
up
[Music]
all right
so and it's Harry Potter he's P The
Starting Line he's climbing up the
ladders you need to lift the cover off
each boat pop the boxes inside and cover
them up then put the cover up back and
it's mission accomplished brilliant okay
so right now we
just leave them like that okay Harry
we'll the boxes up just put them in the
boat it is so dark in the scene I'm
going to have to check it after this see
if there's a video setting I can change
okay wait how do
I eyes no
problem all right just drop it right
there
cool
okay keep it nice and even here so
good
yeah I don't know where oh that's the
way I was about to say it's just putting
it automatically in the
it spot where it needs to go nice almost
there keep
going when guardian Leviosa
right we knew you wouldn't let us
down
yeah there we go nice okay now cover the
Box up with the
tarping back over here brilliant come on
down come on
down I think he's earned a reward how
about a little preview careful ronning a
miney might have to put us in detention
what is in those boxes want to find out
then cast reducto or incendio on that
box yeah think of it as helping us with
our research I think that one's
counterclockwise just cast reducto or
incendio on the
box
Maybe I'm
Wrong oh my
goodness okay we'll do
incendio
what there we go he wasn't looking at
the right
spot that's amazing glad you think
so
all right you guys you guys going to the
DA meeting now all three of you you just
Prov the fireworks are idiot
proof we better go see you at the DA
meeting seventh floor room of
requirement cool we'll be
there n gives us all three of them yes
20 out of 28 da members in the room of
requirement very nice all right I did
see a couple
more brazers we can light over here
hold on let's grab this
though I actually am seeing more and
more Collectibles that they included
it's just the reward you know it's not
enough of a reward there's not really
anything that's tracking this I mean I
guess if we go to Myrtle's secret room
but I think it's just like videos from
the movie or something like behind the
scenes something like
that
all right now this one right
here oh man there's a bunch over
here
dude they go all the way
up I don't know why I decided to say it
that time
but
oo Discovery level eight your spells are
now more
powerful see it's like that's it every
time your spells are now more powerful
congratulations wait why did it show us
down there you've not visited our secret
room for a long time you should see see
what's in there
now Myrtle you know what we just might
have to take a look at some
point if I remember correctly though
it's just I I think it's these behind
the
scenes
Clips probably things that I probably
copyrighted
but actually I don't know if they're if
they're not actual movie clips and it
just behind the scenes stuff then it
might be fine to
show all right I think we got every
torch oh my goodness there's Susan we
should tell her about the room of
requirement what she with crab on you
think you're special just cuz you're
answer in the ministry my father
reckoned your answer a troublemaker
someone will teach her a lesson what do
you want
my father hey wait H wait where is she
over here Harry her I in Ron hey harry
please help oh look they've come to save
their little friend come on in Potter
what are you going to do how can we get
past you'll have to use your wand let's
Jinx the tow Rags we have to get them
away from Susan so we can talk to
her
dueling
time you won't
win
[Music]
stupy oh my goodness how do I move how
do I like Dodge and
[Music]
stuff okay up up is foro expell AR down
down expell
armas why
it
oh I didn't block that
one take this I think up up yeah up up
is
[Music]
foro blast
him okay that does not feel good in the
dueling thanks you were brilliant all of
the I'm sure right analog stick wish as
you julan then you should come to our DA
meeting it's on the seventh floor in the
room of requirements
great
thanks 21 out of 28 let's go I feel like
with the spellcasting in this game the
Wii you guys have to understand the Wii
was super popular at this time and
so man it's been so long but I I feel
like the Wii was kind of like the main
version of the
game and so with the Wii you had this
built in I mean it was perfect for a
wand ever since the Wii was first
introduced people kind of imagin wow
it's like actually having a wand in your
hand what would it be like in a magic
type game in a Harry Potter type
game and I think it was certainly better
than what they came up with
for the PS3 and Xbox versions because
it's just like you had you had to kind
of translate that same style
going into this into this
console no Harry look up at the the
Torches
here oh my goodness he's not looking at
them wait I think I know what we're
supposed to do with the broom Wii leosa
do we do a little cleaning
here
yes we got
some ooh and look what we found love
that okay now can I oh my goodness look
up he's not doing it
man how about over here can we look up
over here I'm even trying to use the
right stick to like jump between
different things just not letting
me wait now where did you
go I guess we can't maybe we can't light
that
one see right there maybe it needs the
logs in
first okay so now how do we clean you
over
here does it light automatically it does
light automatically just when you put
the wood
okay all right maybe we have to just
bring that broom all the way over here
that's probably look
Lea you discovered a hidden Hogwart
symbol all right completely guess we
have to do two
more just out of
range all right no not the
bench
nice all right so it's the same thing as
before we have to take the benches and
match them up with their correct
symbol's
connect all right so we're going to have
red this is gyffin Guardian levosa you
need to go over
here all right that's Hufflepuff so
they're going to be
hi she's like what are you doing
exactly did you see Potter in potions he
got Potter
potions I think Slytherin was this
way and then we've got
Ravenclaw no put that
back put it back
Kyrie nice there we
go see like I actually enjoy solving
these things and doing these things but
then it's just like eh here's a few more
of these orbs
and and it my Spell's getting more
powerful you don't really feel any sort
of tangible benefit I mean maybe when
you're dueling it makes a difference
but's with us okay
so let's see who we want to go after
next so Colin wants to learn a spell as
does
Zacharias then we have Angelina Trophy
Room trap Dean Thomas the
Gargoyles another mini quest with mogle
Flitwick we have to find the book
first wait why are they showing up as
red I can't remember
what what they were
needing all right made a quick trip back
to the room of requirement look at all
the students that are starting to show
up here this is looking pretty cool now
and I did go ahead and keep Angelina
as the next one that we're going to go
find so let's see how we get to her from
here nope NOP no nope nope I just saw
them change at the last second there oh
the portrait okay pass scess
scoundrel
and I did double check my PS3 display
settings there's a a setting called uh
it's like your RGB Black Level doing
today and typically if you're playing on
a
TV it will sort of auto set a lot of
times they recommend you pick limited if
you're on a TV and then be full if
you're on a monitor which I'm I'm
playing on a monitor and I have the
capture card and everything set to full
and and that's what it was on
so I guess this is just how the lighting
of the game looks sometimes it's really
bright sometimes it's really dark and
then sometimes it's fine like right now
like this looks looks pretty solid here
okay where did they say she
was
Angelina
Angelina Angelina Johnson skulls NOP
Hermione
please hi
nope oh my goodness where did she
go okay wait are the footprints still
leading me
there I wish I was as good at quiddit as
you
wait where's it taking us I thought she
was in hereo herione herion is Angelina
some s are smashed up the trophy room
and have gone for I'm locked in we
better get her out if fil CES her hridge
will ban Gryffindor from playing quiddit
forever and that would be the end of the
world wouldn't it come on let's find a
way to get Angelina
out maybe just a little
Ao No can't be that easy can it
okay how about thisi leosa there we go
Dumbledore dude sorry about your
chair wait where is
she I thought she was
just
what what the what the what the
what
[Music]
oh my goodness dude I thought she was
just right
here no way we heard you all the way har
about time too I thought you'd left me
Maloy took my one we need to clear
everything up before those slivering
come back with filch come on
quick okay lots of repairing
needed raro raro we need to cast
reducto what
why her minione oh cuz do we have to put
the trophies backi leosa
oh see know um is looking for an excuse
to B Angelina the gold ones go in the
gold Mar cabinets har oh you got to be
kidding
me you know why do I always have to do
it why why is it always me if only they
hadn't taken my wand if only oh she
doesn't have a wand okay but Ron and
Hermione what's your
excuse what's your
excuse you guys are doing a great job of
bossing me around that's it keep casting
now as soon as I did if we get caught
we'll never be allowed to pay as soon as
I repaired it her money's like no we
must cast reducto she breaks it
again can't believe that trophy
didn't come on come on sit right there
we've almost done it all right now could
be here any
minut oh now you want to help okay need
some help no I need help getting this
trophy oh wait is it actually in there
don't you'll go mad if you this me we
could try casting reducto on the
cabinets but we'll need to repair them
afterwards rcto yeah okay I'm I'm trying
to oh my goodness wardian Leviosa shees
taken my
wand if only there was a lock on system
that worked
correctly uh this is fun is it is it
though F could be here any
minute all right last one I hope here we
go she's in here got you what's the
problem Mr filch I don't know what's
been going on here but I'm keeping my
eye on all of of you
lot thanks Harry that's okay we found
somewhere for the da to practice up on
the seventh floor that's great I'll
bring Alicia and KY with me oh nice is
that going to give us
three it did we only need four
more oh my goodness okay so I'm so
curious to see what's going on with like
Zacharias and Colin like they want to
learn spells so do we go teach them the
spell and then are they are they in the
room of
requirement let's see if that's actually
where I bet they are man I bet they're
already in
there oh wait room of
rewards why don't they you mean we we
don't actually
have room of requirement as an option I
mean I guess it always put you back in
there anyway
but all right so both Colin and
Zacharias they're in the same spot so
that's got to be in there and then we
have Dean finding the Gargoyles Flitwick
we still need to find the book we've got
tasks for mogle as well as Sprout and
Snape and then Zach so wait let's just
go ahead and do let's do Dean and then
all that we should have left is
Zacharias and Colin teaching them the
spell which I think is done in the room
of requirement where everyone is but it
says we're missing four so Dean will be
one then you've got Zacharias and
Colin oh the ptil
twins revealing the room of
requirement I can't remember what we're
supposed to be doing for them so we'll
have to talk to them
again good
idea come on we need to
get
[Music]
up this way portrait Dragon's egg pass
friend to hle
[Music]
Puff hey that sounded so much like na'vi
from
Zelda I I expected to hear listen right
after that Hey
listen
is that Professor homor for history
magic got to this five talking gargo
I've looked in Hogwarts of history but
it doesn't say where they are I can't
even remember Bin's talking about
gargoyles is that boring can i b find
viable them terrific can you let me know
when you find them all that would be
cool yeah okay we'll need to keep our
eyes and ears open there are gargoyles
all over hog but only some of them can
talk no this is like the first one we
should have done because we're wandering
all around the
school oh buddy Okay so we've got this
one with Dean we've got the ptil
twins you know what let's go ahead and
teach
Colin and Zacharias because maybe we can
knock both of those
[Music]
out although hold on should we look for
let's look for a gargoyle here first I
feel like there there should be at least
one here in this
area the question
ising somewhere near here yesy is our
[Music]
always there's manura right
there what are we supposed to do with
this one reducto
maybe no nothing to repair it definitely
lights up though like you can that
mad yeah AO and depulso don't do
anything okay
talking
gargoyle oh wait what was that are you
still keeping your eyes open for
gargoyle I am Remy I
am it'd be great if I had a camera
though that I could move around
all right let's go like back in here
maybe
there's don't forget we need to find
Talking goles oh my
goodness just going to make a
big circle all the way around yeah
nothing I'm just listening right now
much homework to do cuz it sounds like
we're supposed to hear them first we'll
need to keep our eyes and ears open
there are guard got to be something but
only some of
them
nice
ooh no way we have to move all of
these
bye poy we poter going to but lost my
bottle what's it like of course the
Gryffindor wins are on the other
side shut up there's a lot more for
this I'm going
to later you ask
them yeah you guys should watch out that
right there did you guys hear it that
little almost sounded like a
clock wondering if that's supposed to be
the the
[Music]
gargoyle do you
think
again
oh oh that's
cool
like I'm
listening let's see the line
revealed not yet you're going to make me
wait okay oh wait there's there's three
of
Gryffindor oh goodness
Ron I'm so sorry
man let me
move all right Hufflepuff have we done
any of those yet wi Guardian
leosa oh wait did I put a Gryffindor
one the Gryffindor Hufflepuff it's kind
of hard to
tell okay that is definitely a
Gryffindor right
there I think this
one okay that's that's definitely
griffindor oh that's a help puff one all
right look po
got the
badger
will which means this last
one it's going to be
Gryffindor challenge cup unlocked
uncovered every Insignia in the
courtyard wait what's the challenge
cup Myrtle's about to tell me our secret
room for a long time you should see
what's in there
now all right still no luck with any
gargoyles but I think I'm just I think
I'm done looking with looking uh for
gargoyles at least for
now so I think the plan is let's let's
go up there see if we can teach Colin
and
Zacharias the Spells they were wanting
to know may your courage hold and then
we'll try and check the room cuz we've
been unlocking a lot of stuff so I am
curious to see what's in
there if we've added anything new of of
note this place could do with a clean
somebody
says all right back up the
stairs don't
come on we need you over
here are you still keeping your eyes
open for gargoyles oh my gosh she's
literally going to say
that until we find them isn't
she she's just going to keep saying
it oh too funny I mean I guess it's good
to get a
reminder trying to look on the bright
side
so we don't forget all right this way we
need to find talking for Professor Ben's
homework I take it back I take it back I
completely take it back hermoney we're
not going to
forget like how about telling me who
might have the book that you need for
charms instead of just going crazy on
the
Garo oh my gosh but only of them
dude we're going to have
to we're going to have to do this one
soon I cannot take
[Music]
this are you still keeping no quiet shh
shh all right who wanted to learn
Zacharias wanted to learn when are you
going to teach us something useful how
about
teach to keep your big go shut that' be
useful it's okay Ron I know just the
spell to teach Zacharias I'm sure
Zacharias won't mind if he helps you
show the others the
spell yes here it is rck TOA you need to
Target your spell and then gesture with
your wand like
this break
the I thought just stand there zaras and
let me show that was incendia
rra maybe that's different for
dueling keep going this is a great
spell
good brilliant well done everyone hey I
haven't had a chance to practice it yet
oh sorry zachar that's all the time we
have to practice that spell maybe you
can do it another time that was a great
lesson
Harry okay now Colin I
think also okay that's
Zacharias where is Colin it's so hard to
tell some of them
apart okay that's Neville oh it's col
there he is there he is there he is I
don't mind what we practice no I'm hi
Harry I can't wait for this lesson are
we going to do something exciting I bet
we are uh yeah can we blow something up
or try and turn someone into a feret or
what's that spell where you make
somebody completely free so they can't
move petrificus
totalus okay this is quite a simple
spell but it's very useful why is she
taking par an opponent this is my thing
and it as I this is Harry's
thing okay so that's the same one as
reparo but it's for it's for
combat so the gestures are the
same and he does it on Neville too
flashback
to movie
One wow how are you're the greatest
teacher ever thanks let's teach the
others oh wait do we actually have to
teach the others
or did they not did they not learn can't
you come up with any ideas yourself ask
someone else what to do I wasn't even
talking to you
punk oh my goodness man we still need
patil twins Dean Thomas that one could
potentially take a while
Flitwick uh but let's go and before we
do anything else I want to check the
room of rewards let's see what all we
have in there now because we've been I
mean Merl's been talking to us quite a
bit saying you really need to come check
out the room you really need to come
check out the
room we'll see if I was correct in if my
memory was correct and thinking that it
was
mostly like it was it was movie clips or
something like that behind the scene
stuff but maybe there's more there might
be more things in there that I don't
know
about wait where did it
go oh it wants us to go this
way you guys may hear
my my Luna here in the real world
letting me know somebody's at the front
door probably the probably a
package oh there she is right there
there are lots of new things to see in
our secret room
Harry don't say it like that Myrtle
don't say it like that F what that makes
me not want to go every time you
discover things my file gets heavier you
don't know how lucky you are that
portraits can't
jinx
okay room of
rewards get an o in all lessons you have
found two of five flying creatures six
of 12 portrait
passwords oh like here's one right
here what does it say reward unlocked
and then you press square to view okay
so if it shows something from the movies
then I will just edit this part out let
me go ahead and see what else we have
here first
[Music]
though let's
see you're for it now Potter oh it's not
movie initially uh auditioned for Harry
and and Ron um the main part time and uh
and eventually went for Draco um and
succeeded in getting it Potter took his
time getting here what are you going to
do without your pet teacher produ I do
like enjoy playing the B he's just a bit
more uh well fun really put in a
nutshell what do you want Maloy
Professor snake wants to see you in his
office he says it's time for your
remedial potions
lesson
dang you think you're so good useless
loser take this PA who'll show
you oh look they've come to save their
little friends that's kind of cool them
what in a sense is is uh obviously he's
not Harry Potter but in a sense he's
something like him and rert something
like Ron and EM is something like hmani
it's nice to it's nice for me to be the
complete opposite of what I what I hope
to be I like think I portray myself as a
rather gentle young
lad you're going to lose mud blood
lovers there's something there's
something nice about hating the the
villain I suppose the more the more hate
I would get from a child as in the more
ah you're evil the better I've done my
job that's cool so it's all specific
stuff for the game then that I guess
they recorded I I don't know maybe that
was in some of the behind the scenes
stuff they actually put unlike the
extended edition DVDs collector's
edition Blu-rays all those things okay
let's see why are these red does that
mean that I've already oh I haven't
unlocked those yet very very cool very
cool well guys I think that's going to
be a great place for us to end today
seems like you guys are enjoying this
series so far so I think we'll see it
through to the end uh once that next
video is ready you'll see it here on the
right side of your screen now as always
thank you all so much for watching and
I'll talk to you again soon